DAVE BARRY: It's nice to be
here, at Google in New York.
I actually have done a couple
of events at Mountain View,
including one where I performed.
I'm in a rock band of authors,
with Stephen King, Amy Tan,
Mitch Albom, Ridley Pearson,
Greg Iles, Roy Blount Jr.,
Scott Thoreau.
A bunch of authors.
They're very good authors.
We're a horrible band.
We play-- Roy Blount
has described our genre
as hard listening music.
And I say we play-- I call
it the rumor method of music,
which is everybody in the
band is holding an instrument
and playing something.
And then a rumor goes
around that there's
been a chord change.
Whoa, you know.
And we all switch
to another chord,
but not necessarily
the same other chord.
But anyway, we spent a
day in Mountain View.
That was a lot of fun.
They give us this
detailed elaborate tour,
and gave us no
information at all.
I think it's a Google thing.
Like we would say, are
there any questions?
And we'd go, how many
servers do you have?
And they go, we
can't tell you that.
Where's the electricity come?
We can't tell you that.
So anyway, the food was great.
And the cafeteria was great.
And Sergey and Larry
were there dancing to us.
So it was a fun experience.
I'm going to talk about my book.
My book actually has a
major Google component,
which I will get to after
I've softened you up,
and hope that you don't hate me.
So I can talk about it.
But it's a series of essays on
a bunch of different topics.
The title is meaningless, as is
true of almost all of my books.
I write what I think
are funny essays,
and then the publisher
says, well, we need a title.
We need a theme.
And we sort of make one
up at the last minute,
and that becomes the
title of the book.
Although there is
there a sort of roughly
a kind of a happiness
and unhappiness
element to the book.
But mainly it's a
series of essays.
The first one is called
"Bite Me, David Beckham."
And it is based on the fact
that my wife is a soccer writer.
She's a sportswriter
for the "Miami Herald,"
and she covers soccer.
Covers the World Cup.
Does a lot of soccer stuff.
And David Beckham,
who is considered
by many people--
including, I believe,
my wife-- the handsomest
person on the planet,
is trying to start a
soccer team in Miami.
And so he is sort of wooing the
whole city of Miami, including
the media.
And my wife is the main
soccer writer in Miami.
So she spends an
inordinate amount of time
with David Beckham.
Now that ordinarily wouldn't
cause me any insecurity all,
except that I've never been
really good about how I look.
And I explain, in the book, why
I'm insecure about my looks.
And one of the
things I do-- I went
to Pleasantville High
School, right up, not
too far from here.
I graduated, class of 1965,
Pleasantville High School.
And I want to show you why
I'm insecure about my looks.
This is my high
school yearbook photo.
OK?
That is the best I could do.
That wasn't me on a bad day.
This is me looking
as good as I can
in high school-- as a
senior in high school.
I've got, like,
Soviet Union glasses.
Which now, are,
like, retro and hip.
I'd like to punch the
hipsters in the mouth
when they put these glasses
on ironically, because I
had to wear them.
Also, note my hair.
Just a quick note
of my hairstyle.
I'm not saying
it's wonderful now,
but it was really bad then.
My dad cut my hair.
And my dad was a professional
Presbyterian minister.
And he was a good
Presbyterian minister,
but they don't train
them in hair design.
But he bought a pair of--
he worked in New York City,
bought a pair of hair clippers
at Grand Central Station,
and that's how he cut my
brothers' and my hair.
And I agree that we should
get assault rifles out
of the hands of the
American public,
but first we need to get
the hair clippers away
from the dads who are
still cutting hair.
So anyway, I write an essay
about the awkwardness,
the insecurity, of looking
like that as a kid.
And it sort of sticks with
you the rest of your life,
the image you form
of yourself as a kid.
And now having to deal
with David Beckham
suddenly being really interested
in impressing my wife.
I was just going to read
you one little part of it.
After I show, in the book, the
picture of my high school year
book, I say--
Anyway, my point is
that in high school
I was not physically attractive
to the opposite sex, namely
girls.
But, Dave, I hear you remarking,
looks aren't everything.
There are plenty of other
qualities besides cuteness
that girls look for in boys.
Good point.
And when I say good point, I
mean you are a stupid idiot.
The girls at
Pleasantville High School
were not interested in, quote,
plenty of other qualities
besides cuteness.
I know this, because I had
plenty of other qualities
besides cuteness.
Sarcasm, for example.
I had a black belt in sarcasm.
I went entire years without
ever saying anything
that was not basically the
opposite of what I actually
thought.
Also, I could make realistic
farting sounds with my hands.
These are just two of the many
qualities other than cuteness
I had in high school.
None of them impressed girls.
You will never hear a high
school girl say about a boy,
in a dreamy voice,
he's so sarcastic.
I have an essay, also, about--
it's a letter to my daughter.
I have a 15-year-old
daughter, Sophie.
And she's just turned 15.
And so she is eligible for
a Florida driving permit.
And so I've written
a letter to her,
which begins, "Dear Sophie, so
you're about to start driving.
How exciting.
I'm going to kill myself."
I say this because
I live in Miami.
I moved there in 1986
from the United States.
There are many adjustments.
And Miami isn't as
dangerous as it used to be.
People worry about that.
We have a new attitude down
there, a new tourism promotion
slogan-- come back to Miami,
we weren't shooting you.
But the driving is still
quite an adventure in Miami.
When I first got
there, I thought,
nobody here knows the law.
I now realize that
everybody in Miami
is driving according to
the law-- of his or her
individual country of origin.
And there are some countries
where, apparently, it's
traditional to put on
the left turn signal
first thing in the morning.
Maybe put it on the
night before, just
to make sure it's working.
It's the only place
I've ever lived
where the driver's manual shows
you how to give the finger.
Or people will pass
you in a car wash.
And I know you guys are
working on self-driving cars,
I think that's great.
We already have that in Miami.
If you drive in Miami, you'll
see many like, no head at all,
just hands.
These are seniors,
on the road of Miami.
There's a lot of folks down
there, senior citizens.
A lot of them from here, from
New York, who I don't think
drove a lot most of their lives.
I think they took
public transportation.
Then they moved
to south Florida,
and lost the vast majority
of their sight and hearing,
and got driver's licenses.
Which down there come
with your Happy Meal.
This actually happened, there
was a-- you can Google this,
in fact.
Miami police stopped
a 72-year-old man
driving a Chevrolet Cobalt,
which in itself is not
so unusual.
It's where they stopped him.
And this is true-- runway nine,
Miami International Airport.
This man burst through
the perimeter gate
without realizing it,
and was on the runway
when they stopped him.
Which, to me, shows
a lack of awareness.
If I'm driving, and I
realize I'm tailgating a 757,
I would say, I'm not on
the expressway anymore.
But he was out there.
And the thing is,
that's my airport.
I can't get near a plane,
there, with shampoo.
This man was out
there with a Cobalt.
But anyway, we have
a lot of seniors.
And we also have a lot
of people who drive--
this is, again, the seniors.
They divide the labor of
the driving, older couples.
And I have been in the car
with couples like this.
The man drives,
but the woman sees.
He can't see
anymore, but he still
drives, because that's
what the man does.
So she's in the, you know,
the passenger seat, going,
Harry, the light,
it's a green arrow.
Green arrow.
No, no, red, red.
And that's how they--
Anyway, this is the
environment in which
my daughter-- I have
to introduce-- she's
legally going to be
allowed to drive in.
And I point out in
my letter to her
that just because the state of
Florida thinks she can drive,
that doesn't mean-- I mean,
Florida, as far as I can tell,
there's nobody it
doesn't think can drive.
If alien beings arrive
here from another planet,
they'll have Florida
driver's licenses.
The only thing we will
know for sure about them.
So anyway, I wrote a letter to
her explaining how to drive.
And I, in there, discuss
the Florida drivers manual,
which is a festival
of misinformation.
It states, for example, that if
there is no marked speed limit,
you're supposed to
go 35 miles an hour.
If you do that in Miami,
you will receive gunfire
from behind you.
So I have a Q&A
in here, designed
to help my daughter understand
how driving actually
works in the state of
Florida, as opposed to how
the driver's manual says.
And I'll just read you
a couple of Q&A from it.
Q, How is the turn
signal used in Florida?
A, It is used to indicate
other motorists that you do not
realize your turn
signal is blinking.
Q, Could it also be used
to signal your intention
to change lanes?
A, Interesting nobody
has ever tried that.
Q, What is the best kind of
food to eat while driving?
A, Any food, such as a
sandwich, turkey leg, oyster,
or Ding Dong that
can be eaten one
handed, so you still have
a hand free for texting.
Q, What if an
emergency situation
arises that might require me
to operate the steering wheel?
A, Use your forehead
to honk the horn
until the emergency has passed.
Q, My car's engine
seems to have stopped,
and I hear a burbling noise.
A, Are you a senior citizen?
Q, Yes.
A, You have driven
into a swimming pool.
Q, I've had a few drinks, how
can I tell if I should drive?
A, Take this simple test, are
you wearing your underpants
on your head?
Q, Not my underpants, no.
A, Then you are good to go.
Q, What's all that shouting?
A, Are you a senior citizen?
Q, Yes.
A, You have struck a pedestrian.
There's an essay, I call
it "The Real Mad Men,"
which is about my
parents' generation.
I'm a baby boomer, I'm
way older than all of you.
But my parents were
even older than I was.
They were the
greatest generation.
And what got me, writing this
essay, was watching the TV
show "Mad Men," which I
think is a great TV show.
And on "Mad Men," if
you've ever seen it,
you know that everybody drinks
and smokes all the time.
Which I do remember.
It was very accurate.
My parents drank and
smoked like crazy,
and all their friends did, too.
And then they got in
cars, and did everything
we're not supposed to do.
But in "Mad Men" everybody's
always kind of depressed,
and full of anxiety.
And at what I remember
about my parents--
we lived in Armonk,
up in Westchester
County-- was that they
weren't depressed.
That they had great times.
They had wonderful parties.
They had parties long
after they had us, that's
how I know they had them.
We would sit and watch
them drink and smoke,
and just have a great time.
And sing and dance, and
do all these things.
And it occurred to me that my
generation, the baby boomers,
stopped doing that stuff.
We all did, you know--
sex, drugs, and rock 'n'
roll-- until we had kids.
And then we just
suddenly stopped,
and became this very
serious kind of parent
that was into parenting, which
is a verb my parents would
never have used.
And we spent the
rest of our lives
trying to parent our
children, and remove
all the obstacles
from their paths,
and helicopter around them.
And, you know, follow them
around trick-or-treating,
and pounce on them in case
they got something dangerous,
like an apple.
And my parents didn't do that.
They didn't do
any of that stuff.
They didn't take
us to play dates.
They sent us out to play.
They didn't know where we were.
They served us gluten.
Openly.
Openly, people did
gluten back then.
So I talked about that.
And there's a whole essay
about the difference, then,
between my parents'
generation and mine.
In which mine doesn't
compare particularly well.
There's a long essay
about Brazil and soccer.
As I said, my wife's
a soccer writer.
And she goes the World Cup.
And I've gone to the
last two World Cups.
And my daughter, who's 15,
plays on a travel soccer team.
I don't know if any of you
have ever played travel soccer,
but the basic idea,
is every weekend
you get in the car
drive 200 miles,
to play another team that also
got a car and drove 200 miles,
sometimes starting at
the same place you did.
And the reason you do that,
is you have to play in a place
where there's a chance somebody
will be killed by lightning.
Because the rule in Florida is,
you cannot play soccer unless
it's under heavy downpours.
If we ever want to really do
something serious to eliminate
the drought in California,
or sub-Saharan Africa,
schedule my daughter's soccer
team there, and it will rain.
It will rain for days and days.
Anyway, so I talk, in the book,
about Brazil, about soccer,
about the World Cup.
And why I love soccer.
I've become a the
big soccer fan.
But also acknowledge the
criticisms that are usually
leveled at soccer by people.
Many Americans who
detest the sport.
And I'll just give you a couple
of the criticisms I list here.
The players sport haircuts--
I'm talking about pro soccer.
The players sport hair
cuts that were apparently
administered by a blind heroin
addict in the men's room
of a Bulgarian disco in 1978.
Whenever they collide
with something,
such as another player,
a tallish blade of grass,
or an unusually
dense patch of air,
they try to draw a foul by
hurling themselves dramatically
to the turf, grabbing a random
knee-- it's always a knee--
and adopting the agonized
facial expression of a man being
castrated by irate lobsters.
Not to single out
any specific nation,
but there are Italian
players who spend enough time
lying on the ground to be
biologically classified
as zucchini.
I talk about homeownership,
which is the unhappiness
part of the happiness book.
And in an essay that
is titled, Everything I
Know About Homeownership, I
Learned From Johnny Carson.
And it's actually,
it was a true story.
The first humor book I
wrote was in the early '80s,
and it was called "The
Taming of the Screw," which
was a parity of a
do-it-yourself book.
And it was kind of a funny
book tour, because at the time,
I was completely
unknown as a humorist.
And when I went on tour, many
of the radio stations I went to
thought I was a serious
home do-it-yourself guy.
Which made for
some pretty-- like,
I was across from a guy
in, I believe, St. Louis.
A radio guy, been on
radio a million years,
and I was just another
interview he was going to do.
Another interview.
And his eyes were bloodshot,
I'm pretty sure he'd
been drinking at lunch.
And he's thinking, OK, here's
the do-it-yourself book guy,
I'll just ask him a question,
and he'll just take it,
and it'll be over.
And his first question to me
is, so I see-- and he's, like,
opening the book for the
first time ever in history,
for him-- so you talk
about insulating your home.
What do you say about that?
And I go, well, the best place
to put it is on your driveway.
And he goes, what?
Well, it's just easier.
Because if you go up in the
attic, it's like, spiders.
Just put it on your
driveway, and you still
get the tax credit.
So he realized what--
anyway I was that kind.
But the first interview I did,
the first actual book tour
event I did, and the first time
I was ever, ever on television
anywhere-- local or national,
any television showw--
was on the Johnny Carson
show, for this book.
I'm really not, to
this day, sure exactly
how that happened, but somehow
my little humor book ended
up in the hands
of a Tonight Show
producer named Shirley Wood.
She was this tough old
broad, chain smoking.
And she calls me up and goes,
I think your book's funny.
I go, thank you.
And she goes, are you funny?
You know?
And that's really, actually
what she sounded like.
That's actually a little more
feminine than she sounded.
She asked me some
questions, and she said,
OK, remember these answers.
And then she flew me out.
They flew me out to Los Angeles.
And this is-- I've never been
on television for anything.
And that was my first, again.
She came back stage.
I'm in a green room, I'm in
the backstage dressing room
next to The Pointer Sisters.
I'll never forget this.
Like, The Pointer
Sisters, Dave Barry.
That was my experience.
And Shirley Wood comes into
my dressing room and goes,
do you remember what
you're supposed to do?
Yeah, yeah.
Drink this.
And she hands me
a glass of wine.
Not like a little glass, a
water glass full of wine.
And made me drink it.
And that's how I-- really--
and that's how I went out.
So I go out, and I
had a seven minute
spot on "The Tonight Show."
They don't do that much
anymore, where they
have, like, unknown authors.
But there I was, on
the Johnny Carson show,
at the end of the show.
It was called the author's spot.
And it went great.
I later realized
that the reason went
great-- I thought, wow,
television is easy,
you know, everybody laughed.
I later realized it went great
because Johnny Carson was one
of the best interviewers ever.
And he was masterful at
giving me the laughs.
So anyway, as soon as it ended,
as soon as our seven minutes
ended the band starts playing.
As soon as the camera's
off, Johnny Carson
lights a cigarette.
And he turned to me,
and the only thing
that he ever said to me, just to
me, that we weren't on the air
was, I used to try
to do it yourself.
Pause.
You can't do shit yourself.
And I laughed.
And that was it.
Anyway, but I
thought of that when
I was writing this chapter.
Because I've been a homeowner
for a long, long time.
And I've owned many, many
homes over the years.
And I've learned that I
cannot do anything myself.
I have to hire a guy
with a truck to come.
Guy with a truck.
And he always comes, and
there's a certain ritual
to the guy with the truck.
If you are a homeowner,
I'm sure you've
been through this ritual.
He comes in, first he wants
to ask you some questions.
Which I hate, because
if I knew the answers,
I wouldn't call the
guy with the truck.
But he always wants to
know something like,
can you tell me where your
demodulation juncture is?
It should be near the
Boolean overpass valve.
And I never know
where anything is.
I say, I'm sorry.
I'm sitting there looking
at whatever stupid thing I'm
looking at on my
computer screen, which
looks like I'm doing nothing.
But I'm a humor writer.
If I'm looking at a
Japanese game show,
there's a professional
reason for it.
OK?
But anyway, so he goes off.
And then, the part
I hate the most
is when he wants to come
and show you something.
They always have to show you.
Can I show you something?
Mr. Barry, can I
show you something?
And first of all, I
don't want to see it,
because it's not
going to be good.
It's never a good thing.
The truck guy never
says, you see this?
That's exactly the way
that's supposed to look.
That's not going to
cost you a nickel.
That is never what the truck
guy has to talk to you about.
It's always something
very expensive,
that was always done wrong.
And you always want
to say, well, whoever
did it wrong was in a truck.
I'll tell you that, right now.
So anyway, I wrote a
chapter about-- an essay
about not being able
to do things yourself.
Having to call the truck guy.
And the big culprit in
the do-it-yourself world.
The one that keeps convincing
people they can do things
themselves, is like, you know,
the big-- what's the name?
The big hardware store that
advertises all-- why am I'm
blanking on it?
AUDIENCE: Home Depot?
DAVE BARRY: Home Depot.
Home Depot.
They run those
commercials where there's
like a happy, cheerful
homeowning couple.
One minute they're in the Home
Depot store looking at tiles.
You know?
And then they show
like one second
of them wearing goggles and
drilling something, or screwing
a screw in.
And then there's a
whole new kitchen.
Which is a very misleading
view of do-it-yourself.
So I propose, in
my book, a new kind
of hardware store called
Reality Based Hardware.
It would be a hardware
store where if you went in,
we have specially trained
representatives there.
If you went in,
they would actively
try to discourage
you from whatever
it is you were trying to do.
So I have a little
dialogue here,
between a homeowner
and an employee
of Reality Based Hardware.
Homeowner, I want to
install a ceiling fan.
Employee, Really?
Homeowner, Yes.
Employee, You want to install a
machine with long, sharp blades
whirling at high speeds
directly over the heads
of live human beings?
Homeowner, Well, yes.
Employee, I see.
And do you have any particular
expertise in this area?
Any training in the field
the ceiling fan installation?
Homeowner, Um, no, not in
ceiling fan insulation, per se.
Employee, In what, then?
Homeowner, I'm a dentist.
Employee, I see.
And would you comfortable having
a professional ceiling fan
installer give you a root canal?
Homeowner, Well, no,
but that's a different.
Employee, I'd like
you to take a look
at this photograph of a recent,
quote, do-it-yourself ceiling
fan installation.
Homeowner, My god, is that?
Employee, Yes.
His hand.
It landed eight feet away.
I have an essay in
here about Russia.
I went to Russia last
fall, with a friend
of mine named Ridley Pearson,
the co-author of some books I
wrote.
We went for the US
State Department
to Russia, as part of a
program to improve relations
between the two nations.
So you see how
that's working out.
So anyway, I wrote
an essay about it.
You won't really learn
a lot about Russia,
because I never understood
what anybody was saying.
But I had a pretty good
time, except for-- I
ate Mexican food.
I ate a chimichanga.
This is true.
It's like, amazing, how
many non-Russian foods
you can get in Moscow.
And I developed a case of
global thermonuclear diarrhea.
I guess my main piece of
advice is, if you go to Russia,
don't eat the Mexican food.
Just like a weaponized
chimichanga.
And I close the book with
a letter to my grandson.
I became a grandfather last May.
I really, I get no
credit for that.
My son Rob, he actually
works here in New York.
He works for "The
Wall Street Journal."
But he-- well, actually
his wife had the baby.
I'll be technical here.
And I wanted to write a letter
to him, passing on the wisdom
that I've learned.
It was an interesting thing.
You know, I kind
of envision what
it would be like to be like
to be a grandson-- I would
be a grandfather--
it didn't start out
the way I pictured it.
My daughter-in-law is
Jewish, and so they
decided to have a Briss.
I don't know if you're familiar
with the Briss, but basically--
and I want to stress before
I start, I love Judaism.
My wife is Jewish.
She's Cuban Jewish.
My joke is, they
didn't come on rafts,
they parted of the Caribbean.
So I love Judaism.
It's a great religion,
except for I'm not
so big on the Briss concept.
The way it works is,
it's a tradition,
that when the baby is
born, on the eighth day
the baby has to be
circumcised, and then there
are deli platters.
Sometimes on the same surface.
And I looked-- when
I found I was going
to be involved in
this Briss, I looked
in the Bible-- which is
online, you'll be glad to know.
The way it came about, the
story is, in the Bible,
there's a whole explanation
why Jews do this.
Abraham, he's 99
years old, Abraham.
He's like the
patriarch of-- and God
comes to see him, which is
never a good thing in the Bible.
It's kind of like when
the truck guy wants
to show you something.
God never comes to say, hey,
I just turned all of Lake Erie
into beer.
Come on.
Never anything great like that.
It's always something like,
you're going to smite somebody,
you're going to
have to sacrifice,
you're going to have to
build something out of,
you know, goat skins, whatever.
God has got something in his
mind, some bee in his bonnet.
In this case, God
tells Abraham, I'm
going to make you-- you're going
to be the patriarch-- you're
going to be the forefather
of all these kings.
I'm going to give you
the land of Cannan.
Cannan is the biblical word
for what is now Long Island.
But he said, we have to have
a token of our covenant,
is you have to
circumcise yourself.
I'm not kidding, It's
right there in the Bible.
He's telling a
99-year-old man that he
has to circumcise himself.
And you think, like, why
would that be the token?
You know?
Why can't they just shake hands?
And speaking of shaking
hands, not only has Abraham
got to circumcise
himself, but God tells him
he has to circumcise
everybody in his household.
How would you like to
be in that household?
Hey, guess what
God told me to do.
You know?
So anyway, my
grandson had a Briss.
And I was chosen-- I
was given the honor-- I
was told it was an honor--
of being the Sandek, which
is the person who
holds the baby's legs.
While the Mohel-- which is
a Hebrew word for snipper--
performs the actual
circumcision.
That was my first real
interaction with my grandson.
Holding his legs while
he's being circumcised.
And I, you know, I pictured
something like fishing.
You know?
Or learning to
skateboard, or something.
But no-- so I'm
just kind of hoping
he's forgotten all about that.
But anyway, this
leads me to the one
I've been scared to talk about.
There's one other topic I wrote
an essay about in this book,
Google Glass.
And I bought a pair.
With my own money, I bought.
I became-- they
call it an explorer.
Is anybody here--
no, I don't even
want to know if anybody here
is from the Google Glass.
And I wrote about Google Glass.
So I was going to read
you a little bit of it,
and you'll see where
I'm coming from.
And then you can
throw stuff at me.
Before you read this
review of Google Glass,
I want to stress
that I am totally
down with modern technology.
I'm not some clueless old
fart shouting hello, hello
into a mobile phone he
is holding upside down.
Although I have done that.
I love new technology.
I am what is known
as an early adopter.
Over the decades,
I have spent 10s
of thousands of dollars
adopting new technology that I
use for periods of time
ranging from one week
to as long as three weeks.
At which time it
ceased to be as new
as it once was, leaving
me with no choice
but to buy a newer one.
I have boxes and boxes filled
with old new technology.
And still more boxes
containing dense tangled snarls
of cables and power
adapters, that I
would need if I ever wanted to
make the technology work again.
Which, of course, I never
would, because it is old.
I have been buying GPS
units since the days when
they had tiny black and
white screens, and said only,
you are probably in either
North or South America.
I have owned mobile phones
the size of LeBron James.
I early adopted
every single version
of the Windows operating
system, including
Vista, which summoned
hell demons who
possessed your computer
and played pranks,
such as changing all
your verbs to adjectives.
And I continued early adopting
Windows versions after that.
If Windows came out with a
version called Windows Stab You
in the Eyeball With a
Fork, I would adopt it.
And I skip over the point where
own like 11 electric guitars.
Now the point is, I consider
myself to be pro technology,
and knowledgeable about gadgets.
So when I heard about
Google Glass, I wanted it.
I wasn't sure exactly what it
did, it but I knew it was new
and it apparently
involved electricity.
It also involved Google,
of which I am a huge fan.
And this is true, I am.
Google has basically
replaced my brain.
That's also
basically the-- there
was a time when, if somebody
asked me a question,
say, who is Socrates?
I had to manually
think about it.
Whereas now I just Google it,
and boom, I have the answer.
Quote, an ancient dead person.
Google makes thinking
so much easier.
If Google had existed
when I was in college,
I would have spent
the entire four
years getting high and
listening to Moby Grape,
instead of just 87% of the time.
So anyway, I got Google Glass.
It cost $1,500, which
sounds like a lot of money,
until you realize that it's
100% tax deductible if you
write about it in this book.
What is Google Glass?
Its a lightweight
electronic device,
sort of like a high-tech looking
eyeglass frame without lenses
but you wear on your head.
On the front right
side of the device
is a tiny camera and
a miniature screen,
that you can theoretically
see with your right eye.
There's also a tiny
microphone and speaker.
It connects wirelessly
to the internet
through Wi-Fi or
a Bluetooth phone.
So basically, when you
put on Google Glass,
you're wearing a tiny hands-free
computer with direct access
to the unimaginably
vast information
resources of the internet.
Think for a moment
about what this means.
It means you look
like a douche bag.
So anyway.
Seriously, you do.
There is no getting around it.
My daughter-- who has been my
daughter for her entire life,
and therefore has developed
a very high tolerance
for being embarrassed
by me-- refused
to walk into a
restaurant with me
until I removed my Google Glass.
If you go to the official
Google website for Google Glass,
you will see photos of
attractive young people wearing
Google Glass as they
engage in a variety
of modern youthful activities.
Biking, running,
golfing, chopping
organic vegetables, et cetera.
Google has enough money
to buy whatever it wants.
Asia, for example.
So you know they paid the
for the absolute best looking
photos of the absolute
best looking Glass wearing
individuals money could buy.
They still look
like douche bags.
So anyway, that's--
and I'll be honest,
I don't give Google
Glass a great review.
It's probably because
I'm 67 years old,
and I could never
really see the thing.
But I wore them.
Wore them for a weekend.
I went to wedding with them.
I was very popular
with other guests.
And then I did close it.
I know that you've discontinued,
for now, the current version,
and looking at improvements.
And I proposed
some improvements.
And one of them would be,
like an invisibility cloak.
But, you know, when the next
one comes out, I'll buy it.
Because that's the kind
of early adopter I am.
So anyway, that's the
Google part of my book.
So, I don't how
long I've gone on.
They told me there was a
timer, but I can't find it.
So I would be happy
to take questions
on anything, except anything
that requires knowledge.
I'm not good at that.
That's why I became
humor writer.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Our daughter,
as it turns out,
is the same age
as your daughter.
DAVE BARRY: 15.
AUDIENCE: This surprises
me considerably,
because for years we read
your articles and books,
and marveled at the fact
that the timing was perfect.
They were coming
out at just the time
when we needed your advice--
DAVE BARRY: That's why I'm here.
AUDIENCE: --for
what our daughter
was just about to go trough.
So somehow you
wrote those books,
apparently two and a
half years in the past.
Or in no time at all.
DAVE BARRY: Is this
a math question?
AUDIENCE: I was
impressed at the time.
I'm more impressed,
because as I said,
you apparently wrote these
things in no time at all,
and got them out to us in
time to save our lives.
DAVE BARRY: I'm happy to do it.
My daughter's 15, and I've
written some about the issues
with 15-year-old girls,
which is boys, is the issue.
And I don't like them.
And we need a cure for puberty.
But my proposal-- I don't know
if you've had to deal with it--
they come around.
They come around the
house, the boys do.
And I would never let them
in, in a million years.
Because I know what
they're thinking.
My wife lets them in.
What I would do is have a trap.
A steel trap.
A humane trap outside
the front door.
And it would clang
shut, and there
would be a teenage boy in it.
And I would take him
out in the Everglades
and release him in
a humane manner.
But my wife, as I
say, lets them in.
And some of them have
hair on their legs.
I can't stand this.
That alone should be-- anyway.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I hope you
don't mind a question
from a senior citizen.
DAVE BARRY: No.
AUDIENCE: I live in New York
City, so I don't have a car.
I'll get one when
I move to Florida.
DAVE BARRY: Come on
down to Florida, yeah.
What a lot of seniors
like to do is-- just
to make sure they have enough
mass-- get two Oldsmobiles
and have them welded together.
Get that big mass around you.
AUDIENCE: But listen, a
question, not about your book,
but about something that
happened a long time ago,
long before Sophie was born.
Back in the late
'80s, early '90s,
I think you were
one of the first,
if not the first, sort
of mainstream author that
was regularly syndicated
on the network.
On the internet,
ARPANET at that time.
And I think it wasn't with
your authorization, at least
initially.
It was just people
were taking your stuff.
We had a mailing
list for awhile.
I think that Brad
Templeton picked you up
on ClariNet as one of the first
syndicated authors, and such.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
it was like to be an author
and suddenly discover
that, totally separate
from what you thought
was your syndication
pattern, there
was this bunch of geeks
on the internet that
were syndicating your stuff.
How did react to that?
And has it made any
difference in your career
to have been one of the first
internet syndicated authors?
DAVE BARRY: I do
remember it quite well.
And it took me a while to
figure out what was happening.
But people wrote-- back then
we had letters-- and some
sometimes they would write me
letters and send me printouts,
and said, you realize
you're on this?
And I thought it was cool.
What's funny about it-- I
have about nine thoughts
trying to come out once,
so I'll try to pick one.
What was really funny about
it is if the newspaper
business had had any
brains back then,
they would have seen something
that they never did see.
And now the newspaper businesses
is going out of business
because it's run
by English majors.
But I thought, well this
is really interesting,
that all these
people-- you know,
it didn't occur to me to
look at it financially,
because it wouldn't have made
any difference to me anyway.
You know, I was already in
whatever papers I was in.
And I don't think it
was taking anything away
from my way of making a living.
And I just figured, well those
people will also buy books,
and stuff like that.
So I thought that it was great.
I do remember the "Miami
Herald" and Knight Ridder
going way out of their
way to try to stop it.
And failing utterly.
Again, English majors
versus people who actually
understood the internet.
So I just sort of remember it
as kind of an interesting time.
And that's all gone, right?
Those mailing lists,
whatever those?
AUDIENCE: They're
still there, they just
don't get-- they're
not-- in fact,
they probably have more people
on them than they did then.
But it's a much tinier
percentage of the world
than it was then.
DAVE BARRY: At some
point, I got involved--
I was able to
actually post onto it,
or whatever the word would be.
And what I do
remember, was after one
really long drunken
night in London--
I was on a book tour in London
with a very funny newspaper
columnist over there.
And I wrote him a really
ridiculously obscene email
at the end of the
evening, thanking him.
And using the term
Mr. Chuckle Trousers,
which had great
significance that night.
And instead of
going just to him,
it went to everybody
in the world.
So that was my other
big lesson about that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Dave,
thanks for coming.
DAVE BARRY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a couple questions.
DAVE BARRY: What kind?
AUDIENCE: A couple questions.
First of all, my
parents live in Miami,
so I've been looking at
your stuff for years.
DAVE BARRY: Everyone's
parents live in Miami.
AUDIENCE: But we came
from South America, so.
DAVE BARRY: OK.
AUDIENCE: From Columbia.
DAVE BARRY: Columbia!
AUDIENCE: No threat.
DAVE BARRY: No, I have
many Colombian friends.
AUDIENCE: So first
question is, what--
DAVE BARRY: Can I tell you
the first Colombian guy
I met in Miami?
I know I'm interrupting
your question,
but-- This was in the '80s, when
there were a lot of Colombians
there for the wrong reasons.
You know, they were
not software engineers.
And I was meeting, as it
happened, a police officer
in a bar in South Beach.
And he had not arrived yet.
And it was not like a
close friend police,
it was a guy-- I
was doing a column,
and he was going
to meet be there.
So I'm sitting there, and
this guy comes over to me,
and he goes, are you Dave Barry?
And I go, yeah, I am.
And he sits down.
He's a nice guy.
We're chatting away.
After a while I said,
well, what do you do?
And he goes, I'll be honest with
you, I'm a narcotics trafficer.
I said well, do
you mind if like we
carry on this conversation
in, like, another state?
But the other one, the
other Colombian thing-- it's
actually in this book.
In the Uruguay Columbia game
at the World Cup this-- yes,
I sat in the Colombian
rooting section.
And we actually rooted for them.
But I sat with a
bunch of Colombians.
And they said,
where are you from?
And I said, Miami.
He said that's the
same as Colombia.
Which is really kind of true.
And they won that game,
as you may recall.
It was a good game.
But anyway, go ahead.
And can you do the dance
that your team does?
AUDIENCE: I'm not going to.
DAVE BARRY: OK.
AUDIENCE: My first
question is, what
prompted you to move to
Miami in the first place?
DAVE BARRY: OK, you want
me to answer that first?
AUDIENCE: Yup.
DAVE BARRY: Good, then I
don't have to remember it.
The "Miami Herald" hired me.
And for reasons of-- incredibly
poor planning on their part--
they located the "Miami
Herald" in Miami.
Rather than an English
speaking country or city.
But anyway, no.
The "Herald" hired
me, and at first I
didn't want to move there.
I lived in suburban
Philadelphia at the time.
In lovely little quiet suburban,
not even really suburban,
more like a forested place.
And I went to Miami,
and I said, my god, I'm
never going to move down here.
And they said,
you don't have to.
You can stay in Miami and
be our humor columnist.
I mean stay in Glen
Mills, Pennsylvania
and be our humor columnist.
So I, for three years,
was the humor columnist
for the "Miami
Herald," but living
in suburban Philadelphia.
And during those
three years, I kept
visiting-- to do
stories and whatever--
and I came to love Miami.
And I really love it now.
I would never live
anywhere else.
I mean, it is, as you know,
it's a completely insane city,
but it's a really
interesting, fun city.
And it doesn't look like
that out there, now, there.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Absolutely.
So my second question's
sort of related to that.
Do you think your
career would have
been very different had you
not had the craziness of Miami?
DAVE BARRY: Yeah,
it probably would.
I mean, definitely,
probably, 60% to 70%
of the material I've
had over the years
has come from where I am.
So, yeah it would
have been different.
I mean, I still would
have been a humor writer,
but I would never have known
about the kind of wild world
down there, which, to
this day sort of fuels me.
I feel alive when
I'm down there.
If nothing else, because
of the random gunfire.
No.
It's not so bad.
It's really not.
It's not random, really.
It's much more targeted
than it used to be.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE BARRY: You're welcome.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
My dad and I used to
listen to your books
in the car on the way to
school in the morning.
DAVE BARRY: You're
trying to make
me feel even older than
I already am, right?
This is right after the
Civil War, you and your dad.
AUDIENCE: But one of
our favorite books
was "Dave Barry in Cyberspace."
And I was wondering, in
the intervening years,
I'm sure the internet's had
a big impact on your career,
and such.
So is it time to write "Dave
Barry in Cyberspace 2.0?"
DAVE BARRY: I don't know.
Melissa, who introduced me,
was saying the same thing.
That she really liked that.
See, I find that book
hideously embarrassing now.
You know, everything
about it just so dated.
And it moves so
fast, I don't know
that I could ever write about
the internet in a book that
wouldn't immediately
be so out of date.
I wrote a book about
bad songs, once,
it was kind of the same thing.
At the time, when I wrote it,
it was like in the early '90s,
and everybody was sort of
listening to the same music
then.
But you could never--
to write that book now.
And besides, I don't even know
what bad would mean anymore,
to be honest with you.
No, you know, these kids today
with their rock 'n' roll.
I don't know.
I write, occasionally,
about the internet,
it's just so much a
part of our lives,
but I don't think I would ever
try to write a book about it.
I don't think you can
capture it anymore.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVE BARRY: Not that
I even did then.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I have a story to
thank you, and then a question.
So, I didn't grow up here.
I grew up in Israel.
And when I met my
family-- my wife's family
did grow up in New
York, upstate New York.
And it was kind
of important to me
to make a good
impression them but I
had like zero cultural
reference basis.
So I discovered two things
that could make me, like,
impress my wife's parents,
especially her father.
One was reading the baseball
stats the night before,
so I could quote them back
at him in the morning.
But the other thing was,
my view of American culture
was very much shaped
by your books.
And I only had your
'80s books, so it might
have been a little outdated.
But it definitely made a
very favorable impression.
So, who knows, I might
not be here today
if it weren't for you.
Thank you.
DAVE BARRY: Wow!
So you owe me money.
AUDIENCE: What?
DAVE BARRY: The way
I read that question.
AUDIENCE: The
actual question is,
so, the persona you
project in your books
is, like obviously, a
very exaggerated version
of lots of things.
But I've always wondered
if, like, there's
some basis in fact.
For example, when you
describe how you go and buy
a car by sitting at the Dairy
Queen opposite, and so on.
You can see that I'm
reading your old books.
Is that, like, an exaggeration
of something that happened,
or is it just totally unrelated
to your actual persona?
DAVE BARRY: No, no.
I mean, I don't run around
the house making jokes.
And I compare it to, like,
if you lived with a magician,
and all day long he was
pulling coins out of your ears,
you would hate him.
So I think I'm a normal person.
But yes, most humor comes
from something real.
I've always said that what
people laugh the hardest at
is not something that nobody
would have thought of before,
but it's something
that everyone already
does sort of think
on some level,
and you've just
pointed it out to them.
That's when people
really laugh the hardest.
So generally, I never
think in terms of,
like, I'm going to use this.
I'm going to use
this for material.
I'm going to use this.
Just sort of living a life,
material will come to you.
Anyway.
By the way, I went to
Israel the year before last.
With my temple, which I
belong to, because-- like,
there's orthodox, conservative,
reformed-- mine is relaxed.
They'll let anybody in.
So I belong to it, even
though I'm not Jewish.
And I loved Israel, except
for the camel ride, which I'm
sure no Israeli would ever do.
The Bedouin have a camel
ride in the desert.
You go in the bus,
and they stop,
and there's like a train
of camels with saddles,
and then you go around.
And what I remember,
was when they give you
the little lecture-- the safety
lecture-- the Bedouin guy.
When you climb onto
the saddle, he goes,
do not scream when
camel is getting up.
Camel is getting
up a little funny.
And I'm going, like,
how bad can it-- Waah!
But after, like,
riding just, like,
a quarter of a mile on
a camel, which is not
a comfortable
ride, I'm thinking,
no wonder the Middle
East is so tense.
If this is how people
are getting around.
Anyway, thank you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
DAVE BARRY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I told my family
that you were speaking here
today, and my dad said, wow,
well, your younger brother--
who's a freshman
in high school--
has a writing assignment
to write an article
in the style of Dave Barry.
So you're still influencing
many high schoolers today.
DAVE BARRY: Which is a
little terrifying to me.
Over the years, I've
heard that many times.
The one thing that
I hate the most,
is when the teacher
assigns them, read this,
he's a great American humorist.
Like, when I heard
that from my teachers,
I already hated whoever
it was that I had to read.
You know?
And like, every now
and then, the teacher
will send me a whole
batch of-- the students
all had to write something
to me, like, you know,
about my essay.
And usually it's just like, I
read your essay, it was funny.
Sometimes it was like, I
didn't think it was that good.
Well, fuck you, kid, I
didn't ask you to read it.
It wasn't my idea that you
had to read this thing.
I'm sorry.
I don't mean your
brother or sister.
AUDIENCE: I'll let you know
what his sentiments are.
But related to your
style, have you
found that that
voice in your head
has remained essentially
the same since high school?
Or have you
consciously adapted it?
Or has it become more optimistic
or more cynical over the years?
DAVE BARRY: I get
asked that a lot.
I don't really know.
I don't feel as though
I've changed at all.
I must have changed,
because I've
been doing this for like, what,
40 years, something like that.
I don't feel any differently.
If I have changed, it's
been pretty gradual.
I still feel basically
that what I do
is I write silly humor,
rather than satire,
which I always viewed as
humor that was not funny.
Or meaningful,
point making humor.
I'm just looking for
the next easy joke.
I'm not really trying
to help anybody.
And every now and then somebody
will say to me, you know,
people, when I laughed,
it made me feel better.
I was going through a
tough time in my life,
and I read your stuff,
and I felt better.
Or I got along
better with my son.
And I said, that's great,
but I would have done it
even if it made you feel worse.
Because it's the only
skill I actually have.
Anyway.
I don't think I've changed much.
AUDIENCE: All right,
well, keep it up, then.
DAVE BARRY: Thank you, I will.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
DAVE BARRY: No,
it's my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: My dad and
I read your articles
as well, very consistently.
I read "Tricky Business"
and "Big Trouble,"
and I think I have a
very good sense of-- you
have a very distinct voice.
And somehow I totally
missed that "Big Trouble"
was made into a movie.
Someone tells me about
it, and I'm like, oh no.
Oh no, they're
going to mess it up.
There's no way they're going to
capture his voice in film form.
And I was so happy
that it really
felt like it was your
writing in movie form.
DAVE BARRY: I'm
glad you liked it.
There actually is, in my
Russia essay, in this book.
"Big Trouble" is-- I wrote
a novel set in Florida
called "Big Trouble," where
basically a couple of losers
get hold of a nuclear
bomb suitcase.
They think it's emeralds,
but it's a nuclear weapon.
And this was
hilarious madcap plot.
The only problem is that the
movie was supposed to come out
on September 12, 2001.
The day after 9/11.
And so you're not
going to have a madcap
comedy about a bomb in a plane
come out after-- nobody gets
killed in the movie or
in the book-- but still,
it was just all wrong.
So the movie came
out kind of, like,
secretly six months later.
And it didn't make
much of a ripple.
It became sort of a
cult-- you can still
see it on TV, sometimes.
But when I went to
Russia, the one thing
I learned from the talks Ridley
and I gave around Russia.
I would always ask
them, what do they
think our stereotypical
views of them are.
What are their
stereotypical views of us?
Their stereotypical
views of was always like,
we're a bunch of consumer
obsessed people who
don't care about [INAUDIBLE].
You know, totally
accurate, to be honest.
And they always
said ours of them
was that they are vodka
drinking, balaklava
playing gangsters.
I heard the word gangsters
over and over again.
So the last night I was there,
we were in St Petersburg.
And we were at the
American consulate,
where they have, once
a month, a movie night,
where they bring
in Russian citizens
and show them American movies.
These usually people
who speak some English.
And it's meant to just build
relations between the two
countries.
And usually it's some
traditional American classic.
But because I was
there, they decided
to show them "Big Trouble".
Which was fine.
And then he said, would
you introduce the book
to the crowd, and then
answer questions after?
And I said, sure.
So I get up in front of
all of these Russians.
And I just gone over the
plot, because I hadn't seen it
in years.
And I realized that
there are Russians
in-- the good news is there
are Russians in this movie.
The bad news is
they're gangsters.
The only Russian
characters in movie.
Because it was based on an
actual incident in Miami,
where they closed down
a bar in Jai-Alai,
which was Russians
selling surplus
Soviet illegally obtained
military weaponry.
And I turned them
into people who were
selling a nuclear suitcase.
But anyway, I had to get up in
front of all these Russians,
and say, there are
Russians in it.
So, big smiles.
They're gangsters.
You know, like.
But they're really
smart gangsters.
The American gangsters
are stupid in my movie.
So I don't know if
that mollified them.
Did you have a question, or am
I just blithering away up here?
AUDIENCE: That was great.
But I was curious how
much influence you
were able to have in the movie.
And also being a fan of
your "Peter and the" series,
hearing that that may be
becoming a movie as well.
If you'll be able to
influence that in the same way
you influenced "Big Trouble"?
DAVE BARRY: With the
movie, not really much.
I mean, I got to hang around
and watch them make it,
which was fun.
And see how ridiculously
the amount of money
they spend on things like
food when they make a movie.
And Barry Sonnenfeld,
who was the director,
was very nice to me.
And he allowed me
free access to the set
at all times, which I later
learned was because I never
suggested anything.
Usually they don't want the
writer anywhere near it,
because they change everything.
You sort of get used to that.
"Peter and the Star
Catchers," I don't know
that it will ever be a movie.
There was talk that it would be.
This is the prequel
to "Peter Pan,"
that I wrote with a guy named
Ridley Pearson, the guy I
went to Russia with.
And we end up running
a bunch of books.
It did become a
Broadway play-- which
won five Tony awards-- called
"Peter and the Starcatcher."
And it's still touring
the country as a play.
The play was adapted by a
guy named Rick Ellis, who
wrote "Jersey Boys."
And it's actually a lot
funnier than the book we wrote.
We wrote sort of a
straightforward kids' adventure
story.
And Rick made it for grownups,
and very, very funny.
Anyway, that's what
happened to that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
DAVE BARRY: Everybody says that.
You're very polite.
I mean, I had to come.
Katie McKee, back
there, my publicist,
made me come here, because
she wants the food here.
She likes the cafeteria.
AUDIENCE: I had
a simple question
about how do you think
the-- generally, when
I try to show American
humor to my parents, who
are from India, they kind of
think, like, that's very banal.
It's not really--
They don't even
laugh at, like, things
which I laugh at.
And I find it really wise.
Some say, for example, all
the beer is much faster.
I would tell it to my parents,
and they would say, hmm, OK.
DAVE BARRY: You need
new friends, dude.
AUDIENCE: What are
the general humor
that you have found, since
you have presented at Russia--
you covered a lot of Russia.
I was hoping to look through,
like, all right, India, India,
no, no.
DAVE BARRY: I
didn't get to India.
AUDIENCE: And so what
are the sets of humor
that you find-- say,
satire is probably
not-- you do mention
that it's not probably
that cross cutting.
Try talking satire
to your girlfriend,
and making, not so much.
Right?
So that actually works across
all cultures very well.
And what are some which
don't really jell,
and they sometimes
insult people.
DAVE BARRY: Yeah, I've
never really been sure.
The only foreign country
where my humor has,
I know, has done reasonably
well, is England.
And as you probably know,
they speak English over there.
Not as well as we
do, in my-- no.
Even then, it's difficult.
The first book tour
I went on in England.
They all think we're
idiots, I mean, the Brits,
in terms of humor.
They think they are way more
sophisticated than we are.
And maybe they
are, I don't know.
But they feel that
American humor,
it tends to be primitive,
and they're much more attuned
to sarcasm and irony.
Again, they may be right.
But I remember, I
went on a book tour.
I don't even remember the book.
This was, like, a long time ago.
And I would go into BBC
show after BBC show,
that's all I did.
And I would get
into a little studio
with a very well educated
BBC guy, who would
speak much better than I did.
And we'd do an
interview for an hour.
And then I go out and get in
a car, drive through London
traffic for an hour.
And go back into, what
looked to me, like,
exactly the same room.
Maybe even the same BBC guy.
You know?
They have, like, 300 shows.
And do another.
But what I remember was, this
book-- "The New York Times"
had run a book review where
some reviewer who didn't even
work for "The New
York Times" said,
Mr Barry is the
funniest man in America.
And so, of course every,
publicity person ever
since used that quote.
"New York Times,"
funniest man in America.
It really wasn't
"The New York Times,"
and who cares what "The
New York Times" thinks
about humor, anyway?
But every single BBC interviewer
would start this way,
our next guest
has been described
as the funniest man in America.
Which was like,
we'll see about that.
And would have to win them over.
You know?
So it was painful.
But that's the only country
where I'm sure of it.
I, every day practically, get
a book of mine in the mail,
that the publishers have to
send you when it gets published.
And half the time I don't
even know what the book
is, since I can't even read it.
It's not even in our alphabet.
So I don't know what book it is.
I have no idea what it's saying.
I have no if anybody thinks
it's funny anywhere, at all.
I just don't know.
But I think you should
tell everyone in India
to buy my book and find out.
Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
DAVE BARRY: No, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Aw, you're welcome.
I'm wondering how you
feel about-- you know,
Florida humor has become more
popular these days, with,
like, the Florida
Man Twitter account,
and the Florida Woman
Twitter account.
And, like, everything that
people from Florida do.
Like when that guy ate that
person's face, or I don't know,
whatever they do.
DAVE BARRY: That was hilarious.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Not so much for that person
whose face got eaten.
But for everybody else.
I'm wondering how you feel about
Florida humor becoming more,
like, degenerate and
more mainstream, I guess,
and different from the, sort
of like, '80s Florida humor,
where like, it was
mostly cocaine gangsters
shooting each other.
DAVE BARRY: I'm for it.
I mean, in fact, I'm planning
to write a book about it,
about Florida.
There is something-- you know,
after all these years there-- I
used to just say,
well, we're just
saying that because we're here.
But I genuinely think there
is something truly unusually
weird about Florida.
At one point, we just
overtook California
in the just weirdness level.
And there's really no one clear
explanation for what happened,
except that everybody
who's there is there
for a bad reason.
Nobody ever just says, I'm
going to go to Florida,
and live a clean, upright
life, and be productive.
That person doesn't exist.
You know, they went
there because they're
done with working.
Or they know that it's easier
to do illegal things there.
Or you could run for office
in five minutes and win.
My proposal in Miami was that to
streamline our government, when
we have an election, we should
swear them in and indict them
in one ceremony.
I've been in Miami 30 years,
and like, gee, they come and go.
People just show up, and
they're suddenly, like,
pillars of the community,
and then they're in jail.
In Miami is only one, like,
part of the wilderness.
Then there's Orlando, which
is its own kind of weird.
So I'm for it.
I'm for the prevalence
of Florida awareness
out there, because I hope
to write a book about it.
So purely for just venal
reasons, I think it's good.
AUDIENCE: Makes sense.
DAVE BARRY: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So near
the beginning, you
said that when you're
in high school,
you could make farting
noises with your hands.
DAVE BARRY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you still do that?
DAVE BARRY: Well, could
you hold the microphone?
I'm not in-- wait!
That far away?
[FARTING NOISES]
DAVE BARRY: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And I'm sure if Joyce
Carol Oates were here,
you would ask her
to do that, as well.
Well anyway, I think we're sort
of through the allotted time,
and well beyond it.
But thank you all for coming.
This has been-- I
actually enjoyed this.
And I don't always say that on
book tour, but this was fun.
Thank you.